the maesters tell us that Aegon came to
Westeros with fire and blood and
hammered six kingdoms into one fire he
undoubtedly brought as the kings of the
rock reach and Iron Islands learned but
blood has never been in short supply
here ever since the first man carried a
crown into Westeros this first King
United his people against the children
of the forest and is supposedly buried
in the north a victim of a war he
started the first ruler of this land and
the first to die on his throne but not
nearly the last for thousands of years
afterwards a thousand Kings rose and
fell dying in their beds in their
battles in the guards and mistresses
arms the Age of Heroes sounds pretty
until you realize what makes a hero
killing the enemies of his king and to a
king there is no greater enemy than
other kings the Starks and Bolton's the
gardener's and storm Kings the Ironborn
and everyone else even the mighty
Targaryen z' were not immune from
shortened drains Aegon's own son maegor
the cruel was killed by the very Iron
Throne his father had forged if you
believe the tales if you don't then
perhaps the cruel is not a wise name for
a king to earn Darren first of his name
tried to finish his ancestors work and
bring dawn into the fold but for his
efforts he lost 60,000 men and his own
life of eighteen years during the great
Targaryen Civil War known as the dance
of the dragons a king and queen
each vied for the throne dividing their
house and it's dragons against each
other eventually the Queen was fed to
her rivals dragon while her son watched
and the victorious King soon died of his
own wounds by the war's end King's
Landing was smashed cities razed and sad
never to be rebuilt and Dragons had
faded from this world decades later
Aegon the unworthy legitimized all his
bastards on his deathbed inevitably the
greatest of these
daemon Blackfyre declared himself the
rightful heir and ignited yet another
war for the crown after much bloodshed
daemon was killed by an alliance of his
half-brothers on the red grass field all
the same his descendants continued to
threaten the Targaryens until half a
century later when Barristan the bold
slew maelys the monstrous on the step
stones extinguishing Damon's line given
such an illustrious history need we be
so shocked by regicide a war of five
Kings can end only one way with the
death of four yet even in times of peace
a wise ruler knows that when men bend
the knee to a king too often they rise
holding daggers